what flavor is this one did you see this
one I thought it was like an over easy
egg no I don't know that's toasted
marshmallow oh damn don't mama
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys to eat today we have a
special guest Andy Nguyen's here
[Music]
man of a thousand businesses business
Mogul food mogul mogul if you only had
10 seconds to describe herself to
someone brand new that you're meeting
what do you usually say I'm Andy and uh
I guess a creative entrepreneur oh
that's cool owns a lot of different
things and does a lot of weird stuff and
you know what I say back yeah I can see
your boxers entrepreneur oh nice
all the way here yep Maybe
they made it here so where is it thank
you it's not inside South Coast buses
on Bristol Brea dude how big is it dude
whoa these cookies are [__] insane oh
these are massive you guys can see this
the s'more look at the s'more cookies
that's the most popular cookie s'more
one get out of here dude look at the
size of these things guys these are
delicious you you know what you need to
do you need to stop opening Concepts and
tell me so I could be a part of it and
then open it hey this is one cookie look
at this
is that one cookie that's a spell got
stuck on there oh they got stuck on
cookie what did you guys do we all get
the same we got the spooky over here did
you guys all get shares too I got one
with [__] oh yours comes with shares
shares of the company
wait we get that box
dude my game with dividends we just got
a bill
dude this is so [__] good who's got a
Ube one who's got an Uber oh we got the
same one oh we got Uber yeah dude this
one has straight up Freddy are we gonna
take a take turns eating jam on it okay
we're reading they're eating the s'mores
dude look at this [__] which one's your
favorite it tastes it tastes just like
Andy Nguyen it's my favorite's not even
in there what's your favorite one
there's one called the kitchen sink
there's like a bunch of stuff oh that
one looks good dude are you doing this
with that I thought they'll make me
boxes they just gave me these do you own
any companies that directly compete with
this one Hello Kitty
I was in Vegas those far away oh damn
that's really good this is so good wait
how many food concepts are you involved
in yeah I feel like you have a thousand
boots in any capacity which one's name
is like 10 to 12. some I don't put my
name on it
um I just want to say thank you very
much for not getting involved in matcha
or both he's like I wouldn't do that
it's a failing kind of I don't want to
lose money at the seven leaves in Vegas
the three three locations not in Vegas
that's true I do support you I always
forget you seven years oh seven leaves
you're a franchise owner too so how's
that I'm franchisee of the Nevada
territory so how does that feel when
you're like on a business owner of your
own Concepts but then you're also a
franchisee of other Concepts I think I
gotta learn a lot to see how they how
they operate and how they move and grow
so it's good to learn and you pick
things apart the things that you you'll
you will do and you won't do from them
so yeah that's so smart so how did this
concept come to like what made you go I
want to make Next Level cookies and the
name and like like how did it all come
together so I teamed up with the two
girls named Gigi and Jen they're like
the faces of the company so it's like
women random they lead the whole project
and they came from they used to own food
trucks one came from the num nom truck
and she was on like The Great Food Truck
Race and then Gigi had a truck called
the I think the bakery truck but she was
like the original originator of like Ube
products like Ube pancakes and stuff
like she's like she's like early on
before you see and I see it everywhere
but she was like the all the pioneers of
that
so they they develop a lot of the
cookies and then how did you get brought
into it uh help them find the location I
helped them you know concept the project
help them uh raise the money to open the
store so you know they they pretty much
leave the project and I just chill out
taking quick checks so it's kind of like
they were the um like the idea person
and then you come and kind of make it
come to life yeah yeah so they you know
they wanted to work on a concept
together that worked within baking and
we tried different concepts and I think
we all we landed on on cookies and I
helped them you know spearhead on
finding a great location that that fit
for that and how many how many eyes are
more than one location currently just
one location for this project right now
we're still hunting for a second one go
there this is so [__] good this is
amazing
yeah I have a silly I have a silly
question Andy do you ever secret shop
the places that you are like you own a
little bit just see how things really
are the further stores I I do Secret
shop
um because they don't know who I am for
sure so it's a lot easier but I do I
definitely do Secret shop and I've seen
some weird things and uh I'll text my
partner hey man you need to you need to
put this put them in check right now
what secret shopping
didn't know that it was you you know
they don't know who you are and just
pretend like you're ordering and do it
you normally do as a customer you see I
don't even need to do that because they
know who I am and I come up and then
they [__] up and I'm like come on
man they already know
I'm the owner you're [__]
[__] up we don't serve Japanese
we talked about this racism you gotta do
that here they're like sorry boss
we thought you're another [__] sorry I
didn't know it was you what flavor is
this one did you see this one I thought
it was like an over easy egg that's like
a is it egg no I don't know that's
toasted marshmallow first oh damn don't
mind [__] man [__] I was like
there's no yuck there's a fried egg on a
[__] Shadow toasted marshmallow oh my
God this is insane bro it's probably
just totally became a mukbang video I
don't care anymore
and this guy doesn't eat sweets ever
this is [__] crazy that's true you're
a Savory guy are you gonna open one in
Vegas
we're actually we're working on it we're
negotiating for a while I think beef
around the middle of the pandemic but we
never pulled the trigger but we've
toured the area a lot if you do can you
text me
let you know yeah text me personally no
I'll give you some of my shares too yeah
tell me I'll eat at all your places so
far I ate at his Burger Shop
that was pretty good
McDonald's had a baby right in the
middle what kind of burgers are those
like Smash Burgers I love Smash Burgers
all right so let's do the thing right
how'd you get into business
what what keeps you going
uh I got the business almost
19 years ago now one started my first
business in real estate as an appraiser
became a real estate appraiser my best
friend tricked me to become an
entrepreneur and I've been stuck in the
industry ever since uh converted from
Real Estate to clothing to jumping into
food and nfts and brand managing boxers
all this weird stuff that I do now I
lost quite a bit of money in that piece
we should talk about it
how can you help him cope
oh you weren't here Steve last time
definitely not um yesterday yeah
um so with with business right yep
you're are you like pivoting out of
certain places like real estate for a
reason or is it just a personal drive or
interest uh I pivoted out of real estate
appraisal at the time because it was
right before that the first recession
market crash in 0.60708 oh and things
change regulations change got a lot
tougher so I had to add a pivot and the
great thing was I ended up falling into
my my true passion at the time which was
close apparel and clothing and I
remember Arrow yeah I had some you know
luckily I had some decent success in
that time period to get me out of room I
am King do you think like
um you know like obviously with like
businesses and stuff real estate is a
big component of it do you think any of
like your experience in the early years
in real estate does that help you in any
of this new stuff when trying to find
locations absolutely I understand a
location is a lot better I I know you
know great areas how to negotiate deals
a lot better it's definitely helped me
um it's where I'm at now yes you know
what scares me after working at a grade
A Kind of real estate place
so I know you're at you work with Planet
Hollywood no no not Planet Hollywood I'm
GM and then
um all these big like
retail spaces right and everyone that's
worked there tells me so many horror
stories about the contracts like they
give you a sweet deal you get in you
crush it they see what your numbers are
and then they go X Becky we're gonna
bring raise the rent
that is so genius but that is so shady
how do you avoid that or can you at all
it just depends on where you're at with
your brand at the time or what your if
how much hype you have how much control
you know power you have if you're like a
Starbucks if you're like a Starbucks or
in and out you're getting the sweetheart
deal you know they're always gonna give
you the sweetheart deal because you have
more leverage yeah you can definitely
have more leverage You're Gonna Roll Out
the red carpet because they want you in
because let's say like for example when
Apple comes into any Plaza
um all the stores are surrounding it I
think it goes up 30 from the whole quick
traffic wow sales for the sales goes up
like 30. for Apple like everyone comes
such a dick exactly that's the business
term you know the Apple Din Tai Fung in
and out like those types of Brands will
bring in those tons of traffic yeah
because I've actually read somewhere um
uh Chick-fil-A only opens in locations
where there's like I think a Lowe's
within a two mile radius or something
really what or across the street from
every internet for some for some reason
because you're a big company the bigger
the company the more like market
analysis teams they have so they'll
piggyback off of the other companies and
they're like okay that is our
demographic so it has to be like every
Chick-fil-A is like two at least two
miles away from alone so let's say for
you for your pizza place if you're
opening a pizza place what's your dream
neighbor that would help the reptile
store
what's like the best case scenario
neighbor prove Steve right nightclubs
are great because after they come out
they're gonna bite slices of pizza so
you like I heard you talk about
oh we did Real Estate clothing and an
interest food now and I feel like
there's a lot of talk of like um people
trying to find their passions and stuff
did you find that as you get older like
is there a one passion or do your
passions change like as an entrepreneur
or do they all kind of have some sort of
through line or it definitely shifts
because once you do something for a long
time it kind of gets boring as [__] yeah
repetitive and boring so I was like I'm
always looking for what I want to
accomplish next and the ideas and dreams
get bigger because you're doing things
that you've never done before in the
first place you're like well I didn't
know this was possible I didn't know you
could get to this level yeah and once
you keep reaching higher like okay now I
can see now I'm getting up there to the
guys I admire now my okay now I I have a
chance of even surpassing what I thought
I could do and so keep shifting wow so
as we're sitting here like admiring all
these big cookies like these chumps like
these big cookies I'm in the future
already dude the cookies [__] two
years ago
we're just eating his old inventory he's
like get rid of this for me enjoy these
big cookies guys I've moved on do you
have like a time frame of like
it usually takes me this amount of time
to kind of um I don't know get bored of
a certain industry or
when the some of the concepts are just
when they're taking off you're in that
moment and you can't you you're trying
to you're trying to live in that moment
but things are moving so fast and you're
trying to keep up with everything that's
going on and once that moment passes and
you don't make the I think after that is
when I start thinking about different
things like hey we've already either
peeked out or everyone isn't on the same
page anymore and now it's time to go to
the next thing yeah I have a question
for you like I think serial
entrepreneurial lies like it's really
our minds are always like excited about
a lot of different things right so like
you're in a lot of projects and
so like how do you know when to start
stop or like give attention here and not
hear and then like do you over the years
have a flow you CA you catch I start
catching the flow like right now I'm in
I feel like I'm in that that moment
right now where I caught it again I'm
like okay I feel like I got a unicorn I
have that unicorn right now and I need
to run with it sometimes with the
concepts that we have it's usually based
off of
team members that we're working with
over time where things just kind of just
fall apart or you start seeing the red
flags and things that happen you're like
hey well this concept
if I stick with this concept this is the
max I'm able to grow within this time
frame what's a red flag like what would
be a sample one red flag just maybe like
a guy who thinks he owns a unicorn
because I feel like the more experience
you get the more you're easier at seeing
red flags of course I think the red
flags you could tell are
people that aren't team players
um big talkers lazy Walkers yeah lazy
Walkers they're they're not thinking out
on when things uh when things go wrong
they don't know how to think outside the
box no business about it's about problem
solving if you can't problem solve yeah
you know you're you're gonna be doomed
so I have a friend they he has like a a
YouTube channel and then the they got
crushed by the adpocalypse stuff so they
have to have a patreon there's like six
people that go on this channel all the
time
um if there's like if there's like
there's a patreon to keep the channel to
survive and all that stuff like if
you're in that situation what do you
think you would do he can't
[Laughter]
do you have any um like uh do you have
any concepts in mind or business ideas
that you've kind of done the math on and
you know it's not
um it doesn't generate a lot of income
but you really just like yes so those
projects that I want to do there I'm
like okay if this is like Legacy
projects or the things that I you know
I'm I'm I get super excited about they
might not make me the most money but
those are the projects I want to do the
most I think they'll make the most
impact I think for me personally wow and
then do you have like a certain amount
because obviously if you have all of
those then you can you know pay the
bills and raise a family and stuff like
do you have a certain percentage of like
your portfolio like these are for me and
then these are for
it I need to show some success of course
no I definitely have that now because
especially with kids I know I'm like hey
I need to do these projects and I need
to make sure I watch these and make sure
these are taken care of because this
takes care of my these are my grandkids
are going to be set off this right and
then this is stuff I can do this is
stuff I can do for myself for fun why do
you want to hook your grandkids up so
bad yeah
isn't that gonna how do you know you're
gonna like them yeah they're not taking
care of my grandkids I think uh you know
Bill Gates giving all his money away we
won't even give a [__] dollar to
those kids I think Jordan to his direct
kids Warren Buffett's doing the same
Warren Buffett's doing that [__] because
they wanted to be motivated not be lazy
[__] who get addicted to drugs and
[__]
maybe that doesn't have as much with
Asians
I don't know I know a lot of Asians
think to drugs yeah
[Laughter]
yeah I don't know
hmm
generational wealth agents they exist
but they're just not our friends yeah do
you would you ever get into like uh like
the gym business maybe the gym business
yeah or you think that's just a bad bad
business model if I
where I can describe
and kind of bring my own Flair to it
then probably do it disrupt the industry
yeah
that's why I jump into Industries like
like when we talked about last time why
why the hell did I go into the NFC and
like that's crazy jumping in going by
entities and you know I'm like okay I'm
gonna go I think I can go shake things
up I'm gonna open a damn restaurant out
of it and that thing it shook up the
whole industry all the time yeah and
that now if you if you actually do
research and look out there there's tons
of people that started brands with their
nfts because of us there's guys that had
a beer company uh the happy Dad guys
they launched the beef jerky with their
with their nfts a lot of people are
doing different things with it but we
just showed them like hey you do a
tangible use and make actually make real
money off your product in case the value
of your entity does drop and you still
you're still okay it's like shake things
up almost like you're like go-to like
Mantra like does this shake things up
and if it doesn't then I'm not gonna do
it yeah I think that's what excites me
right it gets me that's what gets me
going on like it's exciting to to like
incorporate nfts and like Planned
Parenthood or something yeah yeah yeah
it's like sick idea yeah shake that baby
up
oh geez dude you can do vacuum entities
come on jeez just trying to think
outside the box though that's what it's
about right of course oh I know Planned
Parenthood att's you do like what the
baby would have looked like if it grew
up into a full person [__] and and like
in different stages they evolve over
time into like adulthood yeah
shake it up Sarah is there a way to
marry Jujitsu and food we're like I
think there's a way to do it if you can
grapple the cashier then you get a good
meal half off how would you reinvent the
gym business yeah we need we need help
I have a friend that owns a gym can you
help his gym out yeah
646 Gibbons in downtown I don't always
think with everything it's just you
gotta make an approachable if you're
looking at thinking about the mass
you're trying to make it as approachable
and dumbed down as and easy to enter as
possible Right what if he has like a big
intimidating skull inside is that is
that good for the masses yeah that might
be that might scare people off
this is cool like anything like this
what no what if he has an intimidating
guy asleep in front of the gate with a
bicycle between his legs
like
[Laughter]
um like a traditional like stay at home
take care of the family she's a she's a
she's a preschool special teacher oh
[__] yeah she's so she's you know super
that's rough like yeah that's something
it's a tough job and and she's very
disciplined organized and definitely
puts me inject do you ever like go like
I pay my employees more than how much
you make
holy crap
does she ever go wow my kids get it why
don't you [__] do that a long time
yes
damn because I'm assuming she doesn't
have to work yeah yeah but she like she
probably really enjoys it oh that's cool
that's great that's the best
it's old enough to like go to school and
they're just like so your your wife is
like well I don't have to be home all
day so I'm gonna work or like yeah
they're still yeah four four and one so
one that one's still yeah oh that's like
so Mama Mama work and working dang
that's gangster she works two jobs
as they say yeah well he's got he has 12
companies so all right well now I'm
saying she works she works two jobs but
he owns 12 companies
harder than what I do though
when you're curating Haven or the um the
new center yeah Haven City Market how do
you go about that how do you tell people
you're not right for us how do you try
to get other people to consider it I
think we are scoping out for a mix right
we want Concepts that we know will bring
in a natural crowd already like you know
certain things they'll look for like you
come there you're like I don't want
these crazy things but I want
a good burger or what chicken wings you
know you want you want those some of
those established Concepts but you also
want some of the things that are going
to drive people to make it a destination
like hey I'm like an Ube corn dog like
an Ube corn dog yeah I'm willing to
drive out from San Diego going to West
Covina to try the Ube corn dog because I
can't get anywhere else and we want to
mix I think we want a good mix of both
so like a chain like a Philly steak
places like I want to be in there you'd
have to go you got to come with I think
I think they have to fit they have to
fit within the whole place right they
have to make sense like are they way too
big are they a sub borrow as I don't
want to borrow it sure if there is a
saboro yeah dude
you're lost
within like a certain distance of your
place
it's cheaper rent for them no for you
guys because like you have to be next to
us tomorrow
what if the guy's like I'll pay double
no I can't do it damn even then wow yeah
what if I'm in a strip mall and I'm like
I want a really hard cult calzone
why do they always look good and then
you get it and you're like so
disappointed tricks you every time it's
like so bad they've got it down to a
science just because yeah
it looks good you know how you were
saying that one of the places in there
you would partner with personally yeah
yeah how do you pick which one that's
going to be I think we're you know that
that's a that's a whole again getting to
know the partner uh the whatever their
concept you have to find the goal so it
could be anything it could be anything
we have to we definitely have to you
know we've learned a lot from the past
and we've done similar things that we
haven't posted publicly but this one's
gonna be posted publicly yeah so we're
gonna have to be we're pretty much
getting you're getting in bed with them
right they're gonna be married to this
partner and making sure that they know
how to operate a business we gotta have
to hand hold them a certain way do we
want are these people that we can do we
like actually like we don't like them
and they might do well but we don't get
along though we'd rather not just that's
everything right there yeah so you don't
just show your boxers to anybody just
you today I can't even see them you're
lucky I can see them that's just me and
Steve baby
but thank you check it out
everything's very thought out
foreign